hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the feed hs dot com grand swiss
tournament uh it's alireza ferruccia
versus alexander fritka a really nice
game that we're going to check out uh as
we said um uh during the the last video
the only players in round three that are
still on two points are furuja alexander
pretka here and even sharich of croatia
uh who uh
fought against fabiana corona in round
three we're also going to mention that
game but we are not going to be covering
it so let's uh check out what happened
here so furuja with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh sorry about that
uh we have e5 by pretk uh if you guys
haven't uh seen it check out pretka's
previous game we've shown it it's a
beautiful beautiful queen sacrifice in
case you've missed it the link will be
the first thing you see in the
description below so knight to f3 knight
to c6 and bishop to b5 the rue lopez is
on the board we have a6 morpheus defense
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 uh so
here we have castles uh bishop to e7 and
now rook to e1 so this is all very very
standard uh rue lopezian stuff we have
b5 and now bishop back to b3 and now d6
of course you could go for castle
something like c3 and then d5 if you're
if you're interested in the marshall
attack uh but uh predk says that he
wants the the close set up with the d6
so if rujo goes c3 we have castles and
now h3 and here uh usually people just
go knight a5 then the bishop moves back
we can play c5 then d for you guys have
seen this many times
but here we have rook to e8 so uh still
waiting with that knight maneuver and
the knight might not even go to a5 the
knight might go to b8 and then the c5
pawn will be pushed so here we're
preparing the standard maneuver rook to
e8 bishop is coming to fa then the rook
will control the e file uh d4 uh
grabbing more space in the center and
bishop to b7 we have knight b to d2 and
bishop to f8 now so this is all very
very uh standard stuff with a3 uh a4
again is uh the usual idea here when
black advances these pawns to a6 and b5
you want to try and undermine them with
a4 but a3 also very much playable with
h6 and now bishop to c2 uh so now
there's really no point in the knight
going to a5 you usually want to do it
with tempo as you attack the bishop on
b3 so here we have knight back to b8 uh
preparing that c5 push and now b3 again
b4 also possible but here if yorucci
goes for b3 knight b to d7 and now
bishop to b2 and here
again g6 is
very much playable here c6 is a known
move uh but here we have rook to b8 it's
a very rare idea but it's been played a
few times and um for there's a there's a
very notable game where ponte a4 was
played it was arajaba versus carlson in
the 2014 uh bugarigashimov memorial the
that game ended in a draw and there are
a couple of other games where a4 was
played but now as the rook is here and
well if the position opens up then this
rook might be doing some damage here on
the queen side the bishop here is
undefended uh furuja just plays rook to
b1 and it is now only as of move 16 that
we have a completely new game and now is
what we're interested in so here we have
g6 uh and bishop to d3 now preparing
queen to c2 so c6 still waiting um not
advancing the pawns too far and the
queen to c2 we have knight to h5 the
knight can now come to g7 and then to e6
and from there well it's just going to
be a very strong piece uh we have bishop
to f1 uh well-known maneuver with the
with the light square bishop in the real
lopez you just stuck it in for later and
it's well it's still a very powerful
piece they're doing a lot of pressure
here on the queen side a4 can always be
played but also just uh you know adding
more defense to the king's side so
knight to g7 and now d captures on e5 we
have d captures and now c4 this is how
alireza frees up his dark square bishop
and what can black play here well he
starts with rook to c8 and now rook b to
d1
aligning the rook with the queen on the
d file as this is the only open file on
the board so queen to e7 and now even c5
and this is the really really tricky
move and the thing is uh what can you
play here uh well if you just ignore the
pawn because the pawn can be captured by
the queen and by the knight but for
example you just ignored you play some
like a5 then b4 and white will be very
happy with his setup here
on the queen side now another thing if
you capture with the queen for example
queen captures on c5 then we have this
knight the c4 move
as the knight and d7 is also undefended
so we want to grab that then we want to
grab that and we don't care about this
and now after the rook defends rook to
c7 now we play b4 chase away the queen
and after queen e7 now three of our
pieces are attacking the e5 pawn so we
just recollect our material knight
captures knight captures and bishop
captures for example and white can be
very very happy with this position so
you can see it's not actually a free
pawn but you could also capture it with
the knight this is what alexander does
and now we have knight captures on e5
because one of the defenders of the
knight had just moved knight back to d7
and now again knight d to c4 uh crazy
stuff but now the knight on d7 is
actually attacked twice so you don't
mind if black captures on c4 uh and you
know uh
there's really no point in that rook
captures would be just too strong so why
the black is forced to capture on e5 we
have knight captures on e5 and now rook
e to d8 offering a trade here
and we have queen to c3 putting more
pressure here on this diagonal okay the
bishop is guarding the the knight here
so there's no checkmating pressure but
it's not all that easy for black to find
the move because uh trading along the d
file doesn't really do anything for
black if anything it helps white you
really want to play this c5 move it's
it's really a wonder that is it still
hasn't been played but here it just
loses by force knight g4 and white wins
uh there's no good defense here against
knight to f6 check also the h6 pawn is
hanging so it doesn't really matter what
you do here if you try something like
king h7 to defend it still we're going
to play knight f6 check king h8 and now
queen to c1 again we're going after this
pawn and if g5 then well we can just
trade once for example captures captures
and play h4 and then black's position is
falling apart here so of course uh
alexander knows this and he plays h5 he
takes away the g4 square from the white
knight and now i'll it is a trace once
where rook captures queen captures and
rook to e3 now and here the rook is a
really strong attacking piece because it
can be shifted to the f file it can be
shifted to the g file it can be shifted
to the d file all depends on what black
plays so here we have rook to c7 adding
another defender here but now rook to d3
chasing the queen away queen to e7 and
now queen to d2 preparing rook to d7
and now black really doesn't have a
better better move than just playing
bishop back to c8 because you haven't
played c5 uh uh you know yet and it
doesn't seem like you will be playing it
uh well
uh
anytime soon but but you might we'll see
what happens so here we have f4 now the
d7 square is nicely covered and now
black finally uh takes this opportunity
to play c5 and it it was about time and
now uh already has to decide how to
continue this his pieces are positioned
nicely but he has to play uh very very
precisely so you could shift the rook
somewhere to f3 to g3 like we discussed
g3 does seem very nice preparing f5 but
instead he plays rook to f3 uh you'll
see why we have knight to e6 now and
here comes a4 uh
it's much too early for f5 if you play
f5 knights the d4
attacks the rook here and even if you
capture capture and capture then bishop
g7 and well you you're you have problems
now how are you going to defend this
you're going to lose this knight so
furuja first
tries to create some weaknesses on the
queen side our good friend the light
square bishop also helping out with this
uh so knights to d4 attacking the rook
here but now we have bishop capture c
captures and a captures on b5 with a
capture sun b5 and the bishop captures
on b5 so for the moment white is up upon
but we'll see if he will be able to hang
on to it we have queen to b4 offering a
queen trait and now alireza just trades
with queen captures bishop captures in
the bishop to c for not allowing any uh
rook to see to rook to c1 ideas but also
just putting more pressure on the f7
pawn so king to g7 and now i'm pinning
from this diagonal and now rook to f2
now uh alireza would very much enjoy
bringing his rook into the uh attack as
soon as possible uh but black prevents
this we have rooked a7 he's the one who
wants to activate his rook and not
knight to c6 attacking the bishop and
the rook here so rook to a1 with check
rook to f1 blocking and now rook
captures we have king captures and now
bishop to d2 and now okay now you cannot
defend this spawn but alireza uses this
time wisely so black hat the waste of
your tempe to go after the spawn to
recollect material but now just king to
e2 we have bishop captures on f4 now
king d3 uh this pawn cannot not be
defended and now we have bishop to d7
attacks the knight here so now we just
recollect here uh knight captures on d4
or rather collect we are we are up upon
uh and how can black um continue playing
this well white's plan is to hopefully
bring the king somewhere here and
advance this pawn all the way uh and
promote it into a queen so black needs
to prevent this
we have g5 and now king to c3 we have
bishop to e5 not allowing the further
advancement of the king as the knight
would hang so bishop to e2 attacking the
pawn here and just g4 we have h captures
h captures and now king to c4 this is
how we make progress uh king to f6 and
now king to d5 we have bishop to c8 uh
now we're going for some bishop to b7
check action and then maybe you can
collect the de four pawn but now ah
affirmative just goes b4 he says this
will not work so bishop to b7 check
knight to c6 and now you can't really do
anything about this the knight actually
defends this position really well so g3
you don't want this pawn to remain a
target here and now b5 we have bishop to
c7 not allowing the pawn to go any
further and now king to c5 and now we
will be pushing b6
so king g5
uh now comes e5 even this uh
is possible and uh well uh king to f4
attacking the pawn twice uh but it
doesn't matter all it is just place
bishop to f3 and now if you go after the
pawn bishop captures we're going to play
knight captures and now it doesn't
matter what you play if you go bishop
sorry if you play bishop captures an f3
we're just going to capture it with the
knight
and if you go after the knight it
doesn't uh do you any good because we're
going to capture the bishop on b7 and
then our pawn can easily be promoted to
a queen so after bishop to f3 king the
e3 was played but now we have b6
chasing away the bishop bishop to b8 and
now knight captures on b8 other than
this you really didn't have a a good
move you can't go here you can't go here
so you have to give it up somewhere you
could capture the past pawn but the the
end result is just this end game which
is also winning for white so it doesn't
really make much difference
so here black tried this it's sort of a
tricky idea but you know one that is
very unlikely to succeed knight captures
on b8 and now bishop captures an f3 this
is what black's last attempt is so feel
free to pause the video here and find a
winning move for alireza here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing g
captures on f3 because this will simply
not do and for those of you who uh have
found that uh you are
again a true master of the end game so
congratulations knight to c6 is the move
of course if we capture the bishop then
g2 and this pawn is now a problem knight
to c6 we can bring queen into the game
and after b7 we can simply capture and
open up a discovery here king d6 and
white is still better but is it enough
for a win that will we simply do not
want to find out so instead just knights
the c6 blocking the bishops uh reached
the uh of the uh to the b7 square and
now bishop captures on g2 we have b7 uh
and now unfortunately you do not have
bishop captures on c6 if you had this
then perhaps it would still be playable
uh the problem is after bishop captures
on c6 of course not b8 queen first we
capture here and now after g2 b8 queen
g1 queen you have this unfortunate queen
to a7 check or queen to b6 check for
that matter now the black king cannot
keep defending the the black queen you
have to move the king and now we simply
uh uh pick up the queen so that will be
a problem so the bishop has to move but
you can't move it with tempo so bishop
to e4 was played now b8 queen and now we
have g2 but ferruja just placed a queen
to b2 and he was in this position on
move 63 uh that alexandra pratka
resigned in the game and another
excellent victory for ali reza ferruccia
who is now the only player in the grand
swiss with three out of three so we'll
see if he can keep this uh keep this
going if he
wins it or you know qualifies for the
top two places uh he goes straight into
the candidates tournament so that would
be a great achievement for him
uh and uh well yeah here you resign
because it doesn't really matter what
you do if you bring a queen into the
game then just queen d4 check and again
the king cannot defend the queen and if
you try some silly maneuvers like maybe
bishop here to try and uh block um
something we we simply play knight to d4
and after the queen gets into the game
just queen c3 check king f4 we can pick
up the bishop king g5 queen f6 check and
you know everything is good here uh we
can deliver this check king g4 we can
deliver this check king here we can pick
up the queen and we always win this so
of course predk knows this and after
queen to b2 he resigned the game uh if
you guys are wondering what happened in
the game between caruana and shahrich
also the only player that was on two out
of two going into round three uh it was
a really really hard fought game but in
the end it ended in a draw fabi was
really really pushing but he could not
convert he was up upon into in a uh
bishops of opposite colored end game uh
then he he had the opportunity to grab
another pawn but it simply wasn't enough
there wer there was a one point in the
game where fabi could have gained uh the
winning advantage but uh you know those
are some silly silly engine ideas
uh but yeah now uh for the actual
standings and not for the standings uh
but the thing that i promised you were
not interested in the standing just yet
ferruja is leading he's the only one on
three out of three uh but i promised you
the live ratings list as you know i
messed up
in uh uh one of my previous videos so
here it is
and what it looks like uh uh so these
are the live ratings not the actual
ratings uh magnus of course still in
first place but we're not interested in
that look at furuja he is number six in
the world currently in the live ratings
list uh one point uh uh behind the lavon
arena who is also playing in this
tournament so uh he could uh if virujah
continues this he could easily overtake
not just arun but also yaniponishi
and you know climb up all the way to
number four fabi not so not as likely
but you know if fabi loses a few points
and perugia gains uh he might even climb
up all the way you know to
number three but that requires it like
steady winning and that's very very
unrealistic but you know just just
saying it could happen
uh so yeah that's the game and some
additional info on the tournament hope
you guys uh enjoyed that uh i would like
to thank miklosh madarash uh gustavo
fernandez derek king thc ollie.nl and
the george northworthy for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
grand swiss checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
is happening in the chess world uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day